and I have that it is 101 if the rest of
you want to just try to vote and then
I'll close these polls
getting a last-minute flurry of people
signing on that's wonderful hopefully
everyone can hear
and I do want to introduce myself I'm
I'm Laura McDermott I work for Cornell
Cooperative Extension in the capital
district region and do vegetable and
small fruit extension education and I'm
working for dr. Marvin Pritz on the
Northeast IPM funded webinar series that
we're putting on with a great deal of
help from invited experts throughout the
Northeast region so our thanks to the
Northeast IPM Center for their funding
assistance and to all of the research
researchers that we'll be hearing from
over the next several months and also my
great deal of thanks go to my colleague
Kathy Heidenreich who is has been
instrumental and trying to get the press
releases and all the PR out for this
series and for dr. Marvin Pritz guidance
in it so let's get on with it the first
session that we have scheduled today is
alternative strawberry production
methods and it features two guest
speakers Kathy gemtech who's the senior
extension associate associate at Penn
State University Kathy has a background
in vegetable and fruit nutrition and has
been integral to berry and plasticulture
research in the state of Pennsylvania so
we're really happy to have her and I'm
actually going to let her begin our
begin our talk here in just one second
and I'm jumping ahead slightly I want to
make sure that everybody sees these
additional resources that are listed
here and those are things that you can
access by not clicking on they're not
live links but you can cut and paste
them into your browser if you're
interested in and then any of those
resources and it just in case people are
still not aware of how to do this if you
have a question please type in this
skinny box at the bottom of the chat and
either hit return or hit
sendmessage arrow and I'm just getting a
little feedback from sue that the sound
keeps breaking up I'm sorry sue I I wish
I knew how to fix that and hopefully
it's not breaking up for other folks my
audio and I'll give you a ring all right
so let me move now into the classroom
and I'm going to introduce Cathy dim
check again
senior extension associate at Penn State
University and I'm going to turn off my
talking and give a call and I'm going to
just turn this over to Cathy damn check
well I'm all ready I'll jump into this
at this point if anybody does have
questions or anything feel free to type
them in if we end up getting too many
questions in and against too distracting
we may end up holding them for the end
but for now I'd say if there's anything
that I'm talking about that's unclear to
you please feel free to just type
something in and I'll try to not get
myself too far off track on things
already what I'm going to talk about
here is northeastern approaches that are
used to growing strawberries on plastic
now most of the information does apply
to northeastern United States for those
who are a little west of here there was
some folks from Ohio for example or in
the Midwest
most of what I will talk about would
apply to those situations as well so
we're going to jump into things here you
know most common reasons we get for why
growers are interested in growing on
plastic are listed here weed control is
probably the number one reason that
people give when they're growing
strawberries and matted row production
often they just get tired of trying to
deal with the weeds and the plastic
helps with that problem there are some
other advantages there is a shorter time
to establishment than you might have in
matted row production typically you can
plant during the summer or early fall
and still harvest the next spring
so it cuts off several months that
during which problems might develop
typically you'll get a better quality
fruit primarily in the area of size that
flavor can can also be excellent with
plasticulture berries typically the
fruit will come in two to three weeks
earlier but that really depends on your
management that doesn't have to happen
if you're in the frost pocket there are
some things you can do to to keep the
fruit from coming in too early a frost
is a concern for you
higher marketable yields you may not
necessarily get higher total yields but
if everything is managed well hopefully
you will get a higher percentage of
fruit that is marketable and you're
marketable yields will be higher than
they might be in matted row but again
that's not necessarily true either
berries will tend to pick faster in that
if you have larger berries your labor
costs can then go down for for berries
that are picked ahead and sold as ready
picked and a lot of our growers are
getting a higher price for plasticulture
berries because of the higher quality
now here's the disadvantages
plasticulture berries are expensive to
establish if you were using plug plants
which are the type of plants for which
the system was originally developed for
use with they're expensive at about 21
cents per plant I'm going to plant
population of around 15,000 plants per
acre the cost adds up fairly quickly so
you can you know spend $3,000 on plants
alone it does help if you have a trickle
and overhead irrigation the trickle is a
necessity i'm overhead in this overhead
irrigation and will come in handy in a
couple of situations like for frost
control and then plastic mulch there's
issues on with the cost but also
disposal and and just the environment
accosts of using a lot of plastic can be
an issue too
one other expense it's fairly large as a
row cover that can be as much as $1,500
per acre
depending on the row cover you using and
management in this system is is
intensive so you know there's some some
potential there if you aren't able to
keep up with what's happening in the
planting where you can get into a little
bit of trouble and all that puts it
together into being a high risk type of
situation but there also as a potential
for high returns if you can get
everything working together well so
plasticulture as it was developed for
used I'm in the southeastern United
States where basically it was adapted
from production systems used elsewhere
in that situation typically plug plants
are used plants planted during the fall
either late September early October in
that situation there really are less
times there is less time for problems to
develop typically fumigation will be
used and there will be high raised beds
that'll warm up quickly
most the production is with either
Chandler or camera Rosa and it is used
as an annual system when we take it to
the north typically we'll need to move
that planting time to be earlier either
into mid or late summer you may use plug
plants he also may use dormant plants
and we'll go into some particulars on
that growers may or may not use
fumigation if they can rely on crop
rotation they may not need need
fumigation typically most of the beds
that will be made for plasticulture here
are lower than in the south
most of the growers will use plastic
mulch laying and bed raising equipment
that they will also use for vegetable
production and Chandler still works
really well here but there are some
other varieties that can be used and
typically growers may carry plantings
over for a second year so we will go
into that
more as well I'm just in case you aren't
familiar with plug plants this is what a
tray of plug plants would look like so
when I refer to those you you know what
we're talking about basically they are
runner tips that are taken from plants
routed and in this case a 50 cell tray
and then it'll be vegetative actively
growing plants that are you planted okay
so some of the modifications we use for
using this system in the northeastern
you us really depend on understanding
how the plant grows and responds to the
environment if we understand how the
plant is likely to respond to different
techniques we might use that modify the
environment then we might know what to
change if we need to increase our yields
further just want to try some different
things first I just want to talk real
briefly about how strawberry plants do
respond to the environment
runners are produced during periods when
you have long days and high temperatures
are typical summertime conditions and so
what that means is when we move planting
dates up we may run into some some
issues with with runner production with
having more runners than we actually
want under conditions of cold
temperatures in short days like we have
in the fall in the early spring you'll
have branch crowns formed on plants and
those those are basically you know side
branches on the mother plant each of
those branch crowns can produce one or
two fruit trusses and so we're really
dependent on having those two hive high
yields from a particular plant and then
do it when we have periods of short days
and long nights
that's when flower buds are initiated
that'll happen in the fall and also can
happen in the early spring as well this
is something that isn't strictly
temperature dependent or strictly day
length dependent temperature can affect
this as well finally how the plant
responds
depend with a carrot cultivar and so
this also explains why some cultivars do
better in some areas of the country and
not so well in others and so like I
mentioned modifying any components so
the system will affect how how the
plants respond and what kind of yields
we'll get so you know in a nutshell when
typically we were using plasticulture in
warm areas and we'd use plug plants
planted in the fall you'd end up with
high yields that would result from
having numerous branch crowns formed and
also once those branch crowns are formed
you'd still have a fairly long period
for flower bud initiation so you could
get high yields from those individual
plants planted in the plasticulture beds
in matted row production where we were
planting dormant crowns in the
springtime our yields are really
dependent on having full beds so you'd
have those runners and daughter plants
produced during the long days of the
summer and then flower bud initiation
taking place on those plants during the
fall so even if we got an early fall if
we just had a short period for flower
bud initiation we still had a lot of
plants out there that could could still
give us high yields and all that might
be you know a bit of an
oversimplification but that's kind of
you know in general have you know some
of the thing has some of the things work
and why we need to make some of the
changes we need to make so plastic
culture in cooler areas some limitations
we have we do have a relatively short
fall a short growing season in general
and then cold winter temperatures and we
need to modify some things to deal with
all of these so issues on that short
fall season if we are using plug plants
one of the first field studies we had
done was looking at planting date and
that's what we you know often recommend
people do when they're considering
trying plugs in a plastic culture system
is determine their optimum
planting date for us in central
Pennsylvania which at a research farm is
hardiness zone 6a just to give you an
idea of you know where we're starting
from on this we needed to plant our
plants by the middle of August this is
an issue because there just aren't
enough plug plants available early
enough to supply the demand for them
in in northern areas and even when we
thought we would be able to get plug
plants we didn't always get them when we
thought we would and so what that meant
was sometimes there would be delays in
planting that often frequently happened
for growers and one thing we found was
that for each two-week delay we had in
our planting date we basically cut our
yields in half and so you know that's
that's a big problem to have to deal
with because you just can't get the
yields that you need to be able to pay
for the inputs in that kind of a
situation so we want to look at some
other alternatives for what we can do
here ok if you can't get plug plants you
can try to route your own plugs from
runner tips that you can order from
nurseries that sell them even then you
can sometimes run into issues where the
nurseries may not have the plants may
not go into renter production to the
extent that they need them to do to just
weather conditions or you know for some
reason they've had some sort of a
failure and you just can't still can't
get the tips another option is to use
dormant plants that you can plant
directly into the raised beds instead
and then a third option is to basically
turn dormant plants into plug plants and
so we'll go into just a little bit ok
I'm sorry for interrupting but there's
one question from Paul about what is a
plug plan it sounds like you're going to
talk about that here so sorry for
interrupting yes no no I'm glad you did
I fail to notice that one okay that is a
plug plant right there
and what that is is well I'll go into it
a little bit but but basically what you
do is you take a tip off of off of a
runner that is you know on a mother
plant and then you route it into a
medium in a tray and so it will look
like this little vegetative plant and
we'll go I'm going to flip back forward
here into how you do that pretty much
you need a Mis system now I'm not going
to go into all the details here because
that could be another you know ten
minutes in itself but there is a call
your attention to it right now I'm down
those small freaking sores from down in
Southeast us
ww small fruits org at that site right
there what you can you can visit it and
there is some information on on
producing your own plug plants we also
had an article back in at in Penn
State's small fruit and vegetable
because vegetable and small fruit gives
that back in June 2004 that hopefully
you'll be able to google or use a search
engine for and find that article but it
does give you details on how to do this
but basically what you will do is either
either get runner tips from a nursery
you may be able to produce your own but
you do want to absolutely make sure that
those plants are clean you don't really
you know just want them to be grown
something that you've gotten that's you
know from a planting where they're just
running out into the roam at all you'd
like to be able to keep them clean with
some sort of some sort of way to keep
them clean perhaps using a landscape
fabric or or plastic um on the ground
but what you do is you will cut the tips
off of off of the runners you want to do
that when they're just starting to to
unfold their leaves it'll take about
thirty five days
from the time you cut those plants and
stick them into a growing medium it'll
take about 35 time days from the time
you do that until you have and until you
have a rooted plant that you can use you
need to do this like say typically will
use trays that have 50 cells in them
you'll want to use a media that's fairly
well-drained you'll need a way to anchor
them pair pins
work really well actually for just
holding that little runner tip down you
just leave a little stub on it you
anchor them in keep them under mist that
you'd gradually decrease over the period
of about 2 2 weeks and then you just let
them harden off or at least well you
wean them off of the mist and then
they're good to go so I just just do
want to point out that you need to make
sure you have a clean source of those
and they are fairly you know it's a
fairly easy to route yourself but it you
do need to have the time and some sort
of structure to protect them so you know
there are some inputs into doing that
and the second option which is probably
the best best option for northern
production is to use dormant plants
there you can plant them anytime from
June through July and the issue with
that we talked about how plants will run
or during this summer is that once
you're on plastic you do need to remove
the runners during the summer time so
they can go crawling off of the plastic
and root in the row middles where you
don't really want them so that's sort of
an issue for for them so you'll need to
do that you still have almost a year
till harvest time the one thing I do
want to point out if you're using
dormant plants is that temperature
really has a big effect on the quality
of those plants so if you get them too
early
and you don't have conditions where you
can keep them really cold and by really
cold we mean 30 or 31 degrees we don't
even want them up around 35 or 36
degrees because they basically will
start to use up some of their
carbohydrate reserves at those higher
temperatures so we really want them to
stay at the nursery or in a location
where they're kept cold enough until you
can actually plant them we've had some
growers get into trouble where they've
lost maybe 50 percent of the plants and
in you know they'll just you know be in
a real trouble at that point because
then they have difficulty getting
getting replacement plans so we didn't
want to mention that there is a planting
tool that you can use and rather than
try to use any kind of a mechanical
plant or anything like that we actually
do recommend planting those by hand and
basically you will use this tool which
looks almost like a nail puller or a
metal nail puller that you might use to
push the roots down in into the soil and
that works surprisingly well what we do
is just poke holes in the plastic first
to mark where they're going and then use
the tool to push the plant's roots down
into the ground and again if you go to
the WWWF roots org website there is an
article there where they have
photographs demonstrating how you do
this and that their write-up is actually
for fresh dug plants which are green
plants that we can't use this far north
but but but the principles still the
same and the root system still is very
similar so you know that gives you an
idea of how it works and then if you can
water them after planting that really
helps with getting them established when
we've use dormant plants you know if the
plants are in good shape to start with
and we can get them watered and we have
very good establishment with them and
it's nice to see that the note from kept
there that that he can get good
establishment too so it's you know not
just us in there in our research plots
and where can you get the planting tool
I'm not certain whether Knorr farmed I
believe Norse farms may have it or they
may have instructions on how to how to
make one I know some of our growers if
you see what the pictures look like it's
actually something that is fairly easy
to make yourself and and I actually did
end up using our nail puller which was
about a foot long metal you know metal
thing with a v-notch in the end and it
actually worked pretty well I was a
little concerned I might chop the roots
off with it at some point but anyway I
have seen that point I'm trying to think
of Indiana berry there were a couple
places with the nurseries where I've
seen planting tools advertised one other
thing I want to mention on the dormant
plants is that there is a lot of
interest in using Apogee there had been
research done in Massachusetts and Marv
thanks there there was research done in
Maryland Maine and Massachusetts where
they found that Apogee did increase the
number of branch crowns and decreased
runner production and trials so there is
grower interest in that because it
results in higher higher yields but
that's not a labeled you yet so I just
want growers to be aware of that we're
hoping that in a short period of time
with a relatively short period of time
within the next couple years that we
that label may come through already so
dormant plants another advantage with
them is that you do have a choice of
cultivars a wider choice of cultivars
than you might with plug plants but I
want to point out that not all of the
cultivars that can be used or work well
and matted row production may work well
in plastic culture if they're a similar
product to Apogee for organic users not
that I am aware of
to answer that question there yeah
that's something we may just need to
hold off on for a while and you know see
if there's some some other way of
dealing with that for organic folks in
the future but I would be surprised if
anything came through anytime in the
near future on that let's say cultivars
that work
besides Chandler that our growers have
been happy with Wendy L'Amour
Wendy's got a really nice flavor I'm
really impressed with the flavor and the
sides on that one l'amour has just done
well for us pretty much in every aspect
of production size quality did these
resistance the whole nine yards and then
Dora select & senic are a couple of
other cultivars growers are using that
they seem to be happy with ones that
haven't done so well for us early glow
all the ones I have listed there early
glow all star ovations van Hanna guys
Liotta and we've had yield low yields on
those and some of them really kick into
runner production on the plastic and so
though they might have been a great
cultivar and matted row production you
just end up with a lot of runners in in
plasticulture and not necessarily that
much fruit now one other thing you can
do if you have a particular cultivar
that you really like as as a cultivar in
matted row production you can get
dormant plants in that cultivar and try
plugging your own plants just you know
give it a shot see how they do we do
have a couple of growers who are doing
that the real challenge is getting the
plants into the cells and they do need
to trim the roots a fair amount and it
just you know enough to get them to fit
into some sort of cells will use larger
cells a thirty-two cell tray but the
cell depth can be an issue just getting
them down in far enough now the
advantage of doing this is that you do
know whether your plants are going to
survive or not fairly early on and so
you know you're just putting plants that
are that are doing well out in the field
it's easy to keep a close eye on them
it's easy to take runners on
you know when they're right there in a
condensed location plus you can treat
pests but again that does require some
some labor and having a structure to
protect them now other approaches other
approaches growers in the northern our
cooler regions will use I was holding
their plantings over for a second year
for a second harvest year and that that
seems to work quite quite well you may
have some decrease in yields and very
size but some of that is just related to
management to keeping the planting
disease and insect free and keeping
enough new nitrogen and water water on
the planting if you do decide to try
that you probably want to use a heavier
plastic we use a 1.25 mil embossed
plastic and that gets us through two
years just fine you don't have that much
cost involved and keeping them for a
second year because so much of your cost
is at the front and typically what
you'll do if you want to do that is mow
them after fruiting we don't we do
recommend the growers don't try for a
third harvest here frequently folks will
get through their second year and think
they've plants look pretty good but they
almost always get into trouble during
that third year and explain to you a
little bit why we sometimes have yield
beet creases in the second year and why
we definitely all have yield big creases
in the third year if you look at how a
strawberry plant grows
okay the crown area is basically a
compressed stem and you will have new
roots growing right out of this area
right where the the crown area so you'll
see some of these new roots that are
coming out higher and higher on the
crown as as time goes by as new leaves
are produced this stem will become
longer and taller and so what happens is
it gets higher if the plant basically
gets higher out of the ground you do end
up with more problems with winter injury
and then besides that we often end up
with some problems with insect and
disease build-up you may end up with
additional branch crowns and some
smaller berries on them but again if you
keep the nutrition up there you know you
bet you'll be creases into a definite in
the second year now a couple questions
can you wait till the plants go dormant
and the phone snip off the runners and
start them in the spring I would think
that would be a little difficult to do
you could you could give it a try but I
really doubt that the plants would would
go that long because if the plants are
dormant in the fall you're still going
to have a fairly vegetative you know
runner there and I really think it'd be
a little difficult to keep them in good
enough shape and until the springtime
even even a period of three or four
months I think it might be a little
difficult to do Marv if you can if you
would care to waive weigh in on any
thoughts on that one it appreciate your
thoughts there and yes Richards comment
on oriental beetle that seems to be more
of a problem the further east you go
we've also had some problems with
strawberry root worm is one where we've
had an issue with in carrying plantings
over already and one other thing growers
will ask about typically you'll put on a
ball row cover if you do decide to go
with fall with fall planted or well late
summer or early fall planted plug plants
and you are delayed you know what do you
do in that situation it is possible to
put a fall row cover on fairly early
typically we will say that you'll apply
a row cover when the temperatures when
the high temperatures for dairy they are
either in the high 60s or low 70s they
turday you can't move that up by a few
weeks and and try to get a little more
growth on the plants and adjust so yeah
so Marv's comment dig them in the phone
plant them in the spring that that may
be you know basically the runner tips
just just may not be the way you would
want to go on that but dormant plants
might be of be a way to go there so
thank you Marv fall Braille cover
application just coming back to that if
you do put it on early and I mean by two
to three weeks ahead of when you
normally would expect your temperatures
to your daytime highs to be in the high
60s or low 70s if you put the row covers
on two to three weeks ahead of that you
can make ups for some of the yield loss
by planting the plants there plug plants
late but you just never make make back
the old Blas completely one other thing
I want to point out is if you do that
for some reason it does advance the
spring harvest season and that could be
either good or bad there's just this
carryover effect from putting row cover
on in September that carries over and
makes the plants actually bloom earlier
in the springtime and that's that was
something that surprised us a little bit
I also just want to throw out the
possibility of growing day neutrals on
plastic just because we've been doing
work with them for about the last three
years and they seem to really really
work well on plastic seascape in
particular and so you know if you do
have an interest in growing day neutrals
and we and you think you have a market
for them home for off season berries you
know definitely they neutrals work as
well so this isn't a system that's only
for June bears do pertain to intervals
they neutrals also work well in tunnels
and which Lewis we'll be talking about
in a little while so I'm real protection
I'd mentioned our cold temperatures
choices you can hope for a consistent
row cover that may not
may not do this it looks like there are
some folks who are growing the the day
neutrals I want to take a couple
questions here
you know our market for day nuptials
really seems to vary with who is growing
them and where they are located some
people have had you know have been able
to sell everything they can produce
others you know we're having trouble
moving them so just seems to depend on
the situation yes the four day neutrals
we actually are planting the plants in
the springtime and what we ended up
doing was using dormant plants we
plugged them ourselves and April planted
them in May and then could get good
yields off of them for that first summer
and then we would carrying them over for
a second year and get the production off
for the following springtime after that
the size just decreased too much to
really be happy with with the just the
production after that point we were just
getting a lot of small berries when we
were getting into the second half of our
second year on plastic okay coming back
to our plasticulture the winter
protection you do want to use row covers
if you're in a fairly warm area meaning
you know hardiness zone 6a 6b or
slightly warmer than that if you get
into cooler areas it seems that straw
does does help a lot with getting the
plants through the winter
just putting straw on top alone hasn't
worked that well for us it seems to work
for some other folks we've just had
difficulty with it blowing off and maybe
it's just our our lack of consistent
snow cover to hold it down and and the
fact that we have a windy site where our
research plantings are what's worked
better for us is using straw underneath
a row cover I do want to point out that
when you put straw on a plastic culture
planting at that point you don't really
get any you know light into the plant
anymore
pretty much you know brings any planted
activity to a halt there
but we'll put this straw on later than
we put on a matted row planting normally
we will pull our row covers on during
the fall to get that get some increased
temperatures and plant growth during the
fall and that raises the soil
temperatures and so it's going to be
later that the plants are going dormant
so we are actually have always been very
close to Christmas by the time we put
our straw on so we're really talking the
end of December to do that and so what
we will end up doing is actually putting
the row cover on for the fall pulling it
off putting the straw down and then
pulling the row cover back over again
and you do want the plants to be fully
dormant when you do this so they should
you know have that reddish color to them
be a bit flattened under the Neath a row
cover before you do that okay so the
other issue on frost protection and
that's not just a northern thing that's
that's anywhere it's a problem
everywhere but what's really worked well
for us is either using overhead
irrigation and will actually put the
irrigation sprinklers on over top here
you can see one of the lines I think
right down through there over top of the
row cover and the advantage of this is
you can use the row cover for a lot of
the fast protection and it's only really
once the temperature reaches close to
freezing underneath the row cover that
you need to turn on the overhead
irrigation so that's cut the amount of
overhead irrigation we need to about
half of what would need if we didn't
have the real cover and you can also use
a double layer of row cover that's what
I've gone to the last few years our
thickness on this straw layer and you
want that to be same as in a matted row
planting about four to six inches of
fluffed straw over top of the over top
of the plants
so let's say we're going to move on so
what are our options for making
plasticulture work I'm in the Northeast
or cooler regions using plug plants if
they're available certainly is good if
you can get them early enough but you
know like say there are some issues with
that dormant plants is the other option
carrying them over for a second harvest
year seems to work well consistently and
then you can also do plasticulture in
high tunnels but there you get into more
costs and we'll let Luis get into to
that a little bit so I just want to do
basically a brief review of what we
would what we do and some of the things
that we've talked about to get a
plasticulture planning to work in some
cooler areas you know you'll start out
with your field you'd do the soil test
do all the things you would for any
planting except will normally work in
about 60 pounds in nitrogen per acre
which is a little higher than what we
recommend for matted row production make
our raised beds and spring early summer
some time ahead of time so that you have
those ready to go and then plant dormant
plants mid July works well for us and
need to adjust that for other regions
the further north you go seems to you
seem to need to go a little earlier
further south you can go a little later
or use plug plants and you can use those
from either tips that you route yourself
or from dormant plants and mid August or
tips if you can get them from a nursery
go through and removing runners keeping
the planting water apply row covers in
the fall once temperatures your highs
get you know not out of the low 70s
apply straw mulch to get them through
the winter in addition to the row covers
and then in the springtime you'll take
the straw when your soil temperatures
right around 40 degrees same time base
at the same time same stage of plant
growth as you might have in a matted row
planting just if you start to see the
plans starting to grow it's time to take
the straw
and then you'll leave your rope over
there you can pull the row cover back on
if you want to advance harvest you can
leave row cover off if you want to delay
your harvest but definitely you want to
pull your row cover back on for frost
protection I'm have your overhead
irrigation ready to go at that point
we'll start fertig ating through the
trickle system one to two pounds of
nitrogen per week seems to well work
well for us
go through harvest if you want to carry
them over for a second year you can
basically mow the leaves off the plants
and that's all you'll do but then keep
them watered resume some of the
fertigation to get them get them going
you won't need row covers for that
second fall because you should have
plenty of plant growth out there already
but you will want to protect them for
the winter and then you just continue
once you get you know into that second
winter then you'll just you know go on
through with removing straw the
following spring and harvesting and
that's it in a nutshell so if people
wouldn't mind I think we're going to
hold the questions till the very end
just to make sure that we have plenty of
opportunity for Lois to speak and Kathy
I want to thank you that was great
let me just quickly change these pods
here and put lewis's presentation up
and I'd like to introduce our second
speaker today Lewis dr. Lewis Jed is the
associate professor of horticulture and
the extension specialist for vegetables
and small fruits at the University of
West Virginia and he has also done a lot
of work in Missouri he had a handout
that will be available for you folks at
the very last portion of our session and
that you can download onto your own
computer and I'll make sure to point
that out to you and then one other thing
that I forgot to share with everyone let
me just see if I can make sure to show
this if you can follow my cursor if you
go to full screen for those of us for
those of us who like to see the screen
really big I'm going to enable you to
change it yourself so each one of you
can push full screen and make it take up
the screen and then you don't look at
the attendee list or the chat but that's
up to you to do to do that okay without
further ado I'd like to introduce dr.
Chet webinar series and I mostly work
with vegetables in high tunnels but the
small fruits are a new area that we've
been we've been looking
and so I'm gonna cover some of the
integrated crop management techniques
that you would typically use if you're
growing strawberries within a high
tunnel I think many of you know what a
high tunnel is but for those of you who
haven't encountered one of these
structures they're really just an
advanced way to extend the growing
season in typically through the
Northeast the New England mid-atlantic
region there's a major adoption of this
type of technology to lengthen the
growing season and to exclude past
particularly organic growers finding a
great tool for growing crops organically
without pesticide use or limited
pesticide use and here in the the
mid-atlantic region in West Virginia and
even in the Midwest where I was at
before we were able to extend the
growing season on most crops by three
months but if you'd be really creative
with these high tunnels you can actually
get three crops within a 12-month period
so you're you're able to grow a lot of
food in a very limited space in
you know in a year so that's that's
certainly reason why they're becoming
popular they let you grow crops that you
normally couldn't grow at your latitude
or your region and so it opens the door
for growing crops out of their
traditional season and even varieties
that may be sensitive to cold weather by
putting them in eyetality protecting
them from extreme cold and you're able
to go them much farther north than what
you normally could and then finally
they're they're used to supplement field
production so many many growers who use
these high tunnels use them mostly for
early season production sometimes late
season production but they're also
complementing what they're also growing
in the field so there's just a continual
supply of food over a very long period
of time so that's why they have been
rapidly adopted in their mesh and shapes
and designs on high tunnels I've seen so
many permutations on size and and in
wall designs and and and whatever but
but generally they are solar greenhouse
you're crapping the radiant energy from
the Sun and you're using that to as I
said to advance the growth of the crop
and generally most people define a high
tunnels claim they only have one or
should have only one layer of plastic
but I think the farther north you go
a double layer of plastic on high tunnel
is a great benefit so you know you could
either have one or a double layer of
plastic with the structure so what they
what they also do is I said keep me the
heat over time and this is just a
temperature graph of high tunnel versus
ambient this happens to actually be one
of our strawberry high tunnels and
without looking at the the actual
numbers what we found is just a single
layer a plastic high tunnel increases
the average daily temperature from 7 to
10 degrees per day so that's that's
fairly significant for for crop growth
over time we did a survey on what is
grown in high tunnels and these are some
of the most popular crops I think most
of you probably would expect crops like
tomatoes and salad greens to be widely
grown high tunnels because they're
high-volume long season crops with high
value but strawberries are becoming a
popular crop for high tunnels and also
other small fruits such as brambles
which I think will be discussed a little
later on in this in this webinar series
so there's question on finding a
reasonably priced temperature monitoring
system well well the one that we are
using to monitor temperature is just a
either watchdog or a what they call a
hobo data logger and they can log
temperature for you and we also use
wireless thermometers to look to monitor
temperature so I'm not quite sure the
price differences between those there's
different different types but as I'll
talk about later temperature management
these high tunnels is crucial because
one of the benefits of is a as I said it
is accumulating heat but they're also
manually vented so it's up to the
operator to control temperature as much
as possible so it can either be a too
hot or too cold and that can actually be
detrimental to the particular crop so
we're going to be talking about
strawberries and I think strawberries
are perfect crop for high tunnels mainly
because they are an early season crop
and I preach to my growers here in West
Virginia that we need more supply of
early season crops and berries fit very
well within that that mix the big
question is whether they're profitable
to be grown in the height aisle and that
depends on a couple of factors which
I'll talk about
as farmers markets open earlier there is
a strong demand for berries so early
season berries there is a premium price
for them not quite as much as there is
for early season tomatoes but it is
fairly fairly product so why grow high
tunnel strawberries well I recommend
that whenever you choose a crop to grow
in your high tunnel and there are there
are scores of props that you can convert
us in the high tunnel it depends on your
your particular market but there are
really two things two criteria that I
look at when I when I choose a crop and
its tests have high value and also high
high volume or high yield potential and
there are some crops that have high
value but don't yield much per plant and
that's sort of a problem so remember
those two criteria as we as we go along
we talked about this crop now a lot of
growers who adopt high tunnels on their
farm as I said earlier with the survey
use it for tomatoes tomatoes grow
vertically they yield a lot of fruit per
plant there's a high there's a high
price for early season tomatoes so maybe
8 out of 10 high tunnel producers grow
tomatoes either either
entirely in the high tunnel or in
combination with other crops in the high
tones the strawberries could possibly be
a good crop rotation choice for tomatoes
or compliment tomato production in the
in the high tunnel now Cathy mentioned
different types of strawberries the day
neutrals and the short date or June
bearer types most of my work and
experience with growers have been with
the June Bears although I think the
farther north you go the day neutral
types have tremendous potential we have
just started a project this year with
growing day neutrals in in in the high
tunnels I don't have the data compiled
yet and but I think particularly these
types of crop as types of strawberries
that do well in cooler weather would be
very well suited to farther north such
as the day-neutral types
okay one thing that I highly recommend
when you grow any crop in the high
tunnel is is to make sure that you have
the soil tested prior to planting the
straw the strawberries in the high
tunnel and this is just a picture of
kind of hard to maybe see what it is
exactly but
but this area through here that the
white of white area the crusty area is
actually sort of salt deposits that
build up in the high tunnel from
repeated fertigation of different types
of fertilizers and I have a lot of
growers have questions about that
whether that is you know causing the
salt levels in the soil to be very high
so we recently tested this soil and the
salt levels are very high right around
the emitters but the rest of the soil
does not have very high salt levels the
reason I mention this is strawberries
are very sensitive to salt they are they
will show they will show damage you can
see here they will show damage to the
tissue from salt injury I think I would
picture that in a moment this is salt
damage to to strawberries
some of the marginal necrosis on the
leaves that you see here and so if
you're putting down a lot of fertilizers
and the high tunnels particularly among
your nitrate or urea
you could have a salt buildup or if
you're using certain animal based
compost animal manure based compost you
can have high salts too so just
something to to be aware of so have your
compost tested as I showed earlier this
is compost that we put in our high
tunnel or one of our high tunnels as a
soil amendment it's an animal manure
based compost and again like I said it's
important to have that test either at
the your local
state land-grant soil testing lab or
private lab is there a difference
between everbearing and day-neutral
strawberries I think yes there is I know
Martin Prince would have a better answer
for that and then I would but most of
the varieties you know that we have
looked at have been strictly I think day
neutral types the ever barrow types
which are still
does everybody here Louis now I lost him
there for a second and I I think you're
okay now okay if you had a thing to to
remember is if you are using compost if
you are inclined to use more organic
amendments is to have the compost
testing not only as I said for salts but
also for pH and other other nutrients
most compost is 1 to 2 percent nitrogen
it can be very high in potassium and
sometimes phosphorous depending on the
source and surprising to some folks it
can have also very high pH so using the
too much compost can actually create
problems for crops like like
strawberries so but you can also use
synthetic fertilizers to amend as well
now when we do grow crops in the high
tunnel the crop has grown directly in
the soil under the structure now I have
nothing against using soilless mixes and
I know there's some folks here that use
the compost bags and which I think have
great potential particularly if you
can't move the high tunnel or you aren't
able to leech the soil not tunnel enough
through natural rainfall so I see some
potential for using soilless systems in
high tunnels and I don't highly rule
them out although you know the majority
of runners are using the the native soil
underneath the structure to grow the
crop and if possible the
the strawberry should be placed on
raised beds and these are these can be
made manually which we a lot of girls do
and then they there are some companies
that sell a compact bed shaper which
makes a really nice crown bed that you
can you can plan on in the high tunnel
so similar to this okay or you can use a
flat flat row system but generally I
could use raised bed dapple planning de
is really dependent upon your region of
the country and you know i could say
it's very difficult to generalise with
there's so many different different
folks here on in the meeting but i think
one way to look at it may be as a rule
of thumb is to look at your field
planning date and the high tunnel gives
you almost an extra month so you're
planning window is expanded by three
maybe perhaps four weeks for over what
your field planning data is for these
these particular types of strawberries
so that's one of the reasons why you
know people like hotel production is it
gives you just a larger window to to get
your crops planted so as Kathy was
saying if it's difficult to get plugs
that early in August and early August or
even late July in some regions well if a
high tunnel you have a longer planting
window you can perhaps get plugs a
little bit later in the year
but the problem is that if you plant too
late she mentioned you just don't get
the vegetative growth and the flower bud
initiation in the fall and your yields
are dramatically reduced so sometimes
it's trial and error I know some folks
maybe in your region have been doing
some research of planting dates and
that's probably something you should
look at yeah different planning
arrangements on high tunnel strawberries
go to grow bed or more but if you're
using a two row bed recommend putting on
two two lines of drip tape on the on the
bed so for every row of berries you have
in the high tunnel you should have one
row of drip tape because again you're
protecting the prop from rain and the
crops entirely dependent upon you for
water so you want to make sure that
you're providing enough water and
nutrients nutrients to the crop so
particularly if you move to a three or
four row bed on strawberries you need to
have you know three to four drip lines
per per bed so anyway that's that's
typical planning arrangement there some
growers have tried for row beds and we
have tried it as well and some of our
research the problem you get into with
these high tunnels is that you're
looking at to the 3,000 square feet in
the high tunnel or if you move to a hay
grow system where you have you know
multiple beige in a larger area but the
the inclination is to crowd plants in
there and I think that's a mistake
because you can get more production from
less from an optimal plant population
you could buy just really packing plants
in tight so that's what we found at the
four row bed on strawberries is that
you're actually are paying you you're
paying more for four extra plants but
you're not getting that extra yield so
we have found two or three row bed to be
optimal for for planting in these these
these structures okay so how many plants
can you can you get in there you can get
anywhere from 1,500 to 2,000 strawberry
plants per commercial high tunnel and
this would be a typical spacing I sort
of like to go almost actually distant
between plants and between rows 12 to 15
inches between plants and the same the
same distance between rows on the bed
and sort of a typical staggered planning
arrangement like this
with the bed can be anywhere from 24
inches to as wide as almost 40 42 inches
wide
this is a four row bed with three drip
lines for bed and the plants are very
crowded in there and it's led to Lois
could I
Lois excuse me Chautauqua County has a
question I think is pretty pertinent
about how big is that tunnel do you know
the measurements of the tunnel well most
of the 20 to 30 feet wide and okay thank
you and I think it looks like you might
be starting to talk about sook wisest
questions talking about substrate
systems that she asked and it looks like
you might touch on that now well yeah I
just
my only comments about it is I mean we
have just started this year growing
strawberries in elevated gutters and I
don't have data to share on that but you
know there are some interest in sort of
the vertical growing systems in these
high tunnels and I think there's a
potential there but there have been some
problems with both yield per plant so
someone needs to really work out a
design where there's less shading by
individual plants and the yield levels
are high
you know from top to bottom it was a
recent article in the vegetable growers
news I believe it was in the June issue
were grower up in Michigan was was
looking at vertical growing systems and
actually he's he's designed a system he
thinks works but I think that's some of
the issues that we need to look at in
the future is growing these plants more
vertically getting more plants and also
getting higher yield per plant because
if you're just growing and just a flat
system in this in the soil as I said you
can get a fixed optimal number of plants
but at some point your yield level has
to be high enough to make it problem
capital cost per square foot of a high
tunnel generally they're 2 to 3 dollars
per square foot is generally what the
average and there's like I said there's
a lot of variance in that estimate too
because
depending on whether it's a manufactured
high tunnel or a homemade high tunnel
the cost can be can be pretty pretty
wide but what a lot of our growers have
been doing and I think it might be the
case about the Northeast is poaching old
greenhouse frames from nurseries or
pronounced businesses that are going out
of out of business and then using those
frames for high tones and all they have
to do is just add a young a hip forward
to it so that they can roll up the sides
and get cross ventilation so well I
think it depends like I said I want to
own a year thirty by ninety six high
tunnel the the one that we are about
ready to put plastic on and about two
weeks it's probably cost around seven
thousand dollars with every every
component to it but again like I said
that that price varies depending on them
and the manufacturer
the varieties that you can choose from
are a fairly wide group of varieties
these particular varieties are ones that
are bred primarily for plastic culture
of course you're probably familiar with
most most of these Chandler cameras and
suis charli and Ventana and even
festival those are the ones that we've
grown into high tunnels but I think
there's a there's a lot of potential for
other short-day varieties as Kathy
mentioned such as the wind elem or dark
select and the Seneca as varieties that
could be potentially later than these
varieties and so a mix of these
varieties plus some of those other
Juneberry varieties could give you a
longer production season but our our
most consistent variety has been
Chandler and I know that's been tried
and tested in many regions of the
country but it seems that's not Chandler
in the picture there but it's Festival
actually but it seems to have
consistently high yields and the flavor
that most growers like for for local
markets so but I think the other
varieties that were mentioned could
certainly a compliment Chandler
varieties to add to your high tunnel so
the the reason I mentioned plants yeah
someone she's studying the comment on
using the old hoop houses that were
modified I think that's that certainly
is is the way to starting the high
tunnel production is to is to recycle
frames as much as possible and
and then that way you can you can
certainly cut the startup costs because
they're immediately profitable and you
can recover your cost within a year and
then if you want to you know purchase a
a brand new frame the following year you
certainly would have the money to do it
just sort of adding on to what Kathy was
saying about plants for growing
strawberries or plant sources for plant
types
I mentioned this because the single
biggest production costs of growing
strawberries in high tunnel is plant
costs so you have some choices here on
different types of plants that you can
that you can use you can buy your own
Runner tips and route the plugs yourself
and/or you can get bare root plants or
you can get plugs ready to plant and
we've done all three so the most
economical it's probably going to be
rooting your own runner tips if you can
get router tips in time like I said
because you're planning windows been
expanded by the use of high tunnel you
have more time to get plant material for
the for your high tunnel structure
okay these are some strawberry plant
suppliers Laura mentioned the handout
that I I have that accompanies this
presentation that all this is is listed
within that
well okay the question was 2,000 plants
one pounds of strawberries per plant in
the ground for four to six months that's
that's approximately correct I mean one
pound per plant it should be your base
your base yield that should be the yield
that you should at least get if you're
not getting a pound for a plant the
economics just don't don't work out for
high tunnel strawberries so you should
be somewhere on the one and a half pound
range I believe that actually with some
of these day-neutral types although they
have a longer production season longer
picking season you can actually get
close to two pounds of the plant but for
these june barrow types you should be
getting at least a pound work for this
to cash flow and to make it profitable
for items because for every crop that
you choose in a high tunnel there's
another chore there's another crop
choice that can replace it so they have
to be profitable for that
to be a good choice just the cycle on on
growing the plants in the end the up in
the high tunnel structure generally for
the varieties that I mentioned earlier
such as Chandler cambro so they're
planted in the fall and the planting
date could be anywhere from late July
through mid-september
and depending on your on your region but
they're planted they grow through the
fall the high tunnel keeps them warm
they put on good vegetative growth they
develop branch crowns and then row
covers are sort of interesting to use in
a high tunnel because there really is no
exact formula for using them like what
Kathy was saying with the field of fuel
production actually by using row covers
in high tunnels you can get you know
very early flowering on some of these
varieties and some of these varieties
such as sweet charlie have a very
shallow dormancy or no dormancy at all
and so they will actually fly on in
January or February if if it if it's
warm enough so you can lose production
because of early flowering so you don't
want to put the row cover on these high
tunnel strawberries too early and we use
a medium weight to heavyweight row cover
which is one ounce one and a quarter
ounce
cover and find out that he must have
thanked you but I didn't I think I can
speak generally and say that you
shouldn't use a wrote cover in a high
tunnel before December I think that's a
that's a pretty safe thing to say
now we have used it in our projects
primarily for extreme freeze protection
so if the if the ambient temperature was
going to get below 20 Fahrenheit we
would be using Road covers for
protection on that but we would not keep
the road covers on not on the
strawberries continually and we would
use it the following spring when they
begin to flower so for frost protection
so we were sort of using it
intermittently through the season so
again like I said you don't you don't
want to use it use it too soon lot of
growers use either the floating row
cover cover or will use a low tunnel
which is supported by hoops and either
way is it can be used although you do
get more heat buildup with them with a
low tunnel versus just a floating row
cover okay
now generally when the plants are going
into dormancy in December and the high
tunnel they sort of flatten out and we'd
like to see about four to five branch
crowns on the on the the the
strawberries and the diameter of the
rosette should be about five to six
inches in length and that's a good
starting point for how how your plants
should be going into dormancy problem
that we had last year with a lot of
growers as they we had a very cloudy
fall and we didn't get a lot of growth
in the fall so yields were much lower
this year for a lot of growers so that
that is something that could be a
problem in certain areas if you plan to
early in the high tunnel you can get
runner production and that's something
that you don't want on plastic because
these these plants are growing on
plastic mulch under a plastic cover and
there's no place for the runners to root
and you're not creating a matted row so
you want to just have one central mother
plant producing large fruit from five
five branch crowns or four ten flowers
per branch crown but no daughter plants
so you'll need to pull those daughter
plants off probably a good indication
that you're keeping your high tunnel to
warm is you're getting you're getting
runner production so
that that would be an indication of
temperature management which leads me
into this issue of temperature man's
from the high tunnel because this always
surprises growers at how much time they
have to spend adjusting the vents in
these structures so you see the vents on
on these high tunnels on the side and
you know you generally want to keep the
high tunnel on the cool side for
strawberries because they are a cool
season crop so you know in days where it
might get warm and in the late fall or
even winter days where the temperatures
can get warm you know you may need to
VIN it so rolling up the sides is not is
it's not a bad thing to do even in the
the middle of winter is there more heat
accumulation or high tunnels or low
tunnels well the thing about that is
using low tunnels within high tunnels is
extremely effective
so I mean you're going to get it's sort
of
you know senator synergism between the
two that you give even more but you had
a low tunnel out in the field you know
they do increase the the air temperature
around the plant but eventually they
reach the ambient temperature much
faster than what a high tunnel would but
when you put them in a high tunnel you
almost double the effectiveness of the
row cover so you know that's that's one
of the advantages of using low tunnels
within within the high tunnels
okay so also as I say if you're if
you're not denting your high tunnel
adequately you can get premature
flowering on some of these varieties and
the fires are immediately frozen and
that's lost yield from the plant
there are some growers that that will
use backup heaters and high tunnels for
a lot of crops and the backup heaters
that are used for strawberries are only
used for frost protection but generally
if you use Road covers if you put your
row cover on early enough from the day
before it gets cold that night you can
trap enough heat under the road cover
within the high tunnel to prevent damage
from frost or light freeze dentures got
down into the teens you had a single
layer or plastic you would need a backup
here to prevent damage
okay so then take routine tissue samples
I highly recommend that that's done
primarily a flat first flowering the
following spring and we take about 20
leaf and petiole samples a per variety
for high tunnel that's usually enough to
get you the test and you can send it to
either your diagnosed very through solar
plant nutrition lab on campus or through
a private my offices in this pollination
is an issue on on strawberries and a lot
of crops within the high tunnels because
the flowering is so early that a lot of
the natural pollinators aren't active
yet so a lot of our case in the mid land
in the Midwest these high ten
strawberries would start flowering in
mid to late March well that's usually
well before most natural pollinators
become become available so the
strawberries need to get pollinated
either by air movement or by bringing in
pollinators yourself so the question was
couldn't overhead sprinklers be used for
frost protection in high tunnel yeah I
suppose they could although I really
haven't used a lot of overhead watering
in the high tunnel
most of the watering is done through to
creep irrigation but that's certainly
one one thing that you can do I suppose
if you could keep the water from
freezing on the plastic or anything like
that that would causing the damage to
the
the poly or structure like that so to
solve the pollination issue you can
purchase a Class C hive which has two or
three hundred drones in it and where you
can actually get small nuke boxes of
honeybees but the bumble bees are very
effective pollinators for for
strawberries
and if you don't get good pollination or
if the temperature is very cool when
it's a winter flower and you can you
often get misshapen fruit which is
something you don't want you want good
quality uniform fruit such as this is
with all high tunnel strawberries that
you're seeing now and the frequency of
harvest generally for these these June
bearing types that you're looking at
about a four a excuse me a sixth ten
week period of harvest but if you if you
include de neutrals in you can you can
certainly extend that some things to
consider on I'm running out of time on
the pest management is spider mites and
detritus gray mold spider mite is the
most chronic problem you've had with
growing strawberries and high tunnels
and this is some typical symptoms of
spider mites usually they develop within
a specific area the hot spot usually the
center of the high tunnel where it's
warmest but we have been doing work with
using predatory mites to control spotted
spider mites in high tunnels and it's
been very effective the threshold is
five five mites per leaf and by using
phyto caelius which is a predatory mite
we were able to bring that threshold
down to bring that light level down to
below the threshold so there's a perfect
place to use predatory
insects or mites is the high tunnel
because you're in a closed area you have
a very small space and the the the
insects or mites worked very effectively
in those hotspots this is a particularly
problem if you're growing mixed crops in
high tunnels there's a center of
strawberries here and a lot of different
types of flowers you can use predatory
mites to control Mike's on not only
strawberries but also these other crops
we've used like lady beetles to Athens
are a problem if you're over fertilizing
with nitrogen or if you have too too
much lush growth on the on the the plant
this is botrytis gray mold which usually
occurs your cloudy cool damp weather we
like to remove all the dead leaves as
much as possible this is substrate for
detritus so you want to you want to keep
things under control there's some weed
growth that occurs typically winter
annual weeds such as sub chick weed
occurs around the planting hole that
sometimes need to be weeded one of our
other serious problems is voles or
meadow Mike's and they will get
underneath the plastic they'll
overwinter in a high tunnel and they'll
actually chew on the crown so that's
that's an issue to face in the high
tunnels but you don't get deer damage
like this so there's one advantage of
the high tunnels for strawberry growers
is you do not get deer browsing on the
on there so the yields are 1.2 1.3
pounds I'd like to be around 1.5 pounds
per per plant you can get that yield
level and you can get a price of 3 to 4
dollars per pound which is what most
growers have been getting high Tamil
strawberries can be very profitable but
you have to get that yield level and you
have to get that price range and if you
look at the handout it has all the
production costs and the different
returns for different prices and yields
on strawberries that you can look at and
see if you're actually making a profit
or not so I will close it there and
certainly you want to visit me to the
Cornell high tunnel web site and our
high tunnel website information let us
think thank you very much and I
appreciate I'm sorry to have to kind of
move this along but we have a limited
time and I am what I'm going to do here
we're moving into the final aspect of
the talk there are three polls that I'd
love if people just wanted to give some
response to this information while we
finish up and then in the file share the
upper right corner are several different
one is the handout that was sent to you
in advance from Kathy dem cheque and
then the other two are similar but
slightly different handouts from dr.
Lewis jet about high tunnel growing and
so you can upload those to your own
computer the other thing I want to
remind everyone of is on Tuesday
September 22nd we have a insect
strawberry insect past discussion doctor
Richard calls from the University of
Connecticut and dr. Greg Loeb from
Cornell University are going to be
talking about root weevils and sap
beetle and tarnish plant bug
respectively and I do hope all of you
will get that announcement for
connection and if you can make it
wonderful if you can't just disregard
the announcement but we decided to
start sending because we're getting so
much activity for the registration it
was just easier to keep all of you in
one list and send it out but before we
log off if anybody else has any
questions for either Cathy dem cheque or
Louis jet we could take those now just
for a couple of extra minutes I know
there was one question that was asked
several times what is the difference
between Oh Cathy answered that great no
real difference for between day-neutral
and everbearing possibly day-neutral
might not be quite correct and
yeah yellow all it is is really the day
neutrals aren't really day neutrals and
right now there seems to be moved okay
I'm all repeat flowering okay great
that's good to know
all right does anyone else have a
Heather Bryant what is the optimum pH
for growing strawberries do either of
you okay good that was what I was going
to say is there any other question that
looks like a kind of people of typing
rapidly Quinn Smith forever bears if I
want to overwinter do they need to be
renovated like June bearers no not on
plastic yep
any other questions looks like people
have stopped typing and most people have
responded to the polls and I think
that's it then we made it just in the
nick of time for the log off and I
really want to thank again the Northeast
IPM Center for funding this series of
webinars
I want to thank Kathy dem cheque of Penn
State University and dr. Lewis jet from
West Virginia University for their
participation and I look forward to
seeing all of you or some of you on
Tuesday September 22nd and if any of you
have any comments and would like to
email me please feel free to do that
thank you again for your participation
Nora are you still there
knew it
you